hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve
letter combinations of a phone number so
we're given a
string of digits that contain
only two through nine so the digits are
only going to contain the numbers
2 through 9 and we want to return all
possible letter combinations that the
number
could represent and so basically what
this problem is about
is like when you wanted to text people
with old phones you only had
these digits right so in order to have
characters you'd map a number like two
to the characters a b c
and you can see the reason we're doing
two through nine is because
one was not mapped to any digits right
so we don't need to consider the one
two was mapped to abc three was mapped
to d
e f basically each number or each digit
four five six each one was mapped to
three characters some were mapped to
four characters seven is mapped to four
nine is mapped to four different
characters so then if you're given
a string of digits let's say two 3 in
this
case right 2 3 is our string well how
many different
output strings could we have here you
can see we have a
bunch right we have 9 different strings
why do we have 9 different strings
because this two could be three
different characters it could be
a b or c this
three could also be three different
characters d
e f so three times
three is nine so basically we can have
we can have nine different combinations
of these characters right
we could have a d we could have a
e we could have a f right and so on and
so on right so
we could have b e b b f
and then do the same thing for c right
so then you would have nine different
strings
and so basically you can tell that this
problem right like writing out the
solution like this it's not that
difficult because we're gonna basically
be forced to brute force this problem
and it's a backtracking problem because
we have to brute force it right we have
to basically find every single
combination
that we could get using the given digits
and
you might have noticed i've been doing a
lot of backtracking problems recently
and that just goes to show you that
backtracking is a very important
algorithm
so let me just show you kind of the
drawing of the backtracking solution so
luckily for us in this case we're only
given two
three right and so we only need to find
okay two maps to these three characters
three maps to these three characters but
we know in total
we it's possible we could have a four we
could have a five if we had a four
we know four maps to the next three
characters after this
so g h i i think unless i'm forgetting
something
and basically we could have any
character right from
two through nine so we're going to need
to create a hash map
or some kind of way to map every
character from
or basically every digit from two all
the way
to five six seven all the way to nine
right and
map them to the characters that they end
up being right we know nine is
i think gonna be xyz we're basically
gonna have to hard
code this map of characters there's not
like a clean way to do it mainly because
some of the characters
i think seven has four characters right
seven is mapped to four different
characters and
so whatever but this is a pretty small
hash map right so it's not a big deal if
we have to hard code it
but now let's just look at this problem
itself how are we going to solve it well
so the first character is 2
right so 2 could map to three
different characters so two being the
first digit it can map to a
b or c right and the next character we
know or the next digit is
three so from a we could have three
different
characters that follow after it we could
have a d
we could have an e or we could have an f
and that's going to be true for
every single one of these right we could
basically put a d
e f after each of them and this
is the entire backtracking tree so based
on this
what's our solution because remember we
want to know the strings
that this could map to well this is one
string
this is one string this is another
string so basically for
each of the leaf nodes in this tree
we're going to
follow the entire like list of
characters that came before that's going
to be the output strings right a
a d a e a f
and so on right b d b e
b f and the exact same thing for c
so when you visualize it like this this
is actually a pretty simple problem
so now you just need to know how to
write this backtracking algorithm and
i'm going to show you how to do this
recursively but before i do that the
time complexity for this
is basically the number of combinations
that we're going to have
so the question is how many different
output
could we have for a string let's say the
input string is length
n how many different outputs could we
have well since we know that there are
some characters like i think
nine maps to four different characters i
think w
x y z actually so the brute force is
gonna be
four to the power of n that's how many
outputs we could actually have right
because maybe we'd get
a string s equal 9999 right so
basically we'd have four choices for
each of those characters so 4 times 4
basically 4 to the power of n which is
the
length of the input string right so
that's the number
of output strings that we're going to
have and the length of each
output string is going to be the same as
the length of the
input string right so really the time
complexity is going to be
big o of n times
4 to the n and basically this is the
worst case time complexity
okay so now let's get into the code
which is going to be
fairly short so the first thing we want
to do is have a result
this result is going to contain the
combination strings that we're trying to
build
and the next thing we want to do is
create a map of digits right we want to
take
every single input digit that could be
possible like two and map it to the
characters
that are possible so abc right for two
and
unless you wanna see me type this out i
think i'm just gonna copy and paste it
so
this is what our digit map is going to
be like and you can verify this if you
have an old phone laying around that
this
is the correct mapping from digits to
the following
uh string characters so now let's write
that backtracking function
it's going to be a recursive function
and i'm going to
declare this function inside of this
function so that we don't need to pass
in these parameters every time we call
this backtracking function
and we also don't need to pass the
digits that we're on i'm only going to
pass in one variable i which is going to
tell us what index we're at in
the digit string that we're given as the
input to our
function and i'm actually going to pass
in one more variable
so the current string meaning basically
the current string that we're building
so let's say our input was
uh one two three and the current string
would contain something like
a right so if we've we've only visited
one so far we'd have a
and then we'd want the next two
characters from two and three
so we know the base case is if i
is greater than or equal to the
length of digits or actually an even
better base case would be
our current string let's say the length
of the current string
is exactly equal to the length of digits
that means that we've
basically been able to take every single
digit and then map it to a character
because current string is going to
contain those characters
and if that is the case then we are
allowed to take our result and add to it
the current string that we just
built and then since this is the base
case after that we can just return
if this is not true though that means we
haven't
finished building the current string
that means we need to continue
going through the digit that we're at
right at index i
so let's create a loop to do that
so basically i'm going to take digits of
i that's going to tell us the current
digit that we're at right and i want to
take this digit that we're at and i want
to map it to the list
of characters that it maps to right so
if we had nine we know nine maps to
w x y z so how can i do that well that's
why we created this
digit to character map we can take a
digit
and then map it to a character so digit
to
character i'm going to take this digit
and now basically this is going to be
the
that string that it maps to and i want
to just go
through every character in this string
so for every c every single character in
this string
i want to brute force this right so for
every single character i'm just going to
call backtrack
i'm going to make that recursive call
right so
for i we're going to increment i by 1
because we're moving to the next digit
and for the current string we're going
to just take the current string that we
were given
and add one more character to it the
character that we're currently visiting
c and that's actually all that we have
to do
we have our single base case and we have
our recursive case you can see that the
only thing
that might be different for you is that
our recursive call is inside of a loop
so with this backtracking function
complete
now let's actually call this
backtracking function so
we the parameters to give it are going
to be 0 for the
index and the current string is
initially just going to be empty right
but i'm actually going to need to make
one last modification so we're only
going to need to call backtracking if
the digit string that we're given
is non-empty and the reason is because
if digits was
empty then our recursive call would be
called and then we'd execute the base
case
once so then we'd end up returning this
as our result we'd add the empty string
to result
but in the way this problem is defined
if
digits if digits was empty like this if
digits was just an empty string the
output that they actually want is just
an
empty array like this so that's why we
have to
put this inside of a condition but other
than that all we have to do is now
return
our result and the function is complete
so you can see that it's pretty
efficient about as efficient as you can
make a problem like this even though
it's a rel it's what's it called it's an
exponential function right
but i hope that this was helpful if it
was
please like and subscribe it supports
the channel a lot and i'll hopefully
see you pretty soon
you